oh my it is time for animal crossing new
horizons direct i've been excited about
this for
ages
uh a super long time i put like 500
hours into new horizons um i have a tour
of my beautiful five-star island here on
this youtube channel if you would like
to check that out and then i just
abandoned my villagers because i kind of
ran out of stuff to do
i've been waiting for an excuse to come
back
i'm hoping this direct is it because i
didn't build that island that tirelessly
but nothing so
very excited to see
what's going on
in animal crossing new horizons let's do
it
hello everyone thank you that music got
me through the early pandemic horizons
direct
[Music]
today we'll be going over the details of
the update for the animal crossing new
horizons game
[Music]
the update is scheduled to be released
on november 5th hell yeah that's closer
than i expected
let's take a look at the free content
coming to your i can't wait
god i never managed to find any way to
put my big
dino bones
[Music]
something's coming to the museum
yeah
finally
this is the roost a cafe owned by the
composed brewster oh my goodness look at
this handsome that's expensive maybe no
that might be the price of a product
relax while brewster's serving the cup
of his finest selected coffee god look
at his mustache
[Music]
when i drink coffee i'm like i don't
know i like it
[Music]
by using the animal crossing series
amiibo figures and amiibo cards in the
roost you can invite characters of your
choosing
some of them may bring along company as
well
[Music]
invite other nintendo characters but
that probably doesn't
work with the game design
this is captain you'll find him lounging
around on your island's pier how a big
cutie he'll ferry you to a destination
via his boat yeah pride and joy
because there's a bunch of stuff from
previous uh animal crossings i only
played new leaf i didn't uh play any
others in series
then i remember being in them that
haven't been in new horizons yet it's
worth the journey just to be serenaded
by his sea shanties
[Music]
knows about
you might dock at an island with
mysterious flora
i like these the vines are really or an
island with a different season
oh that's handy time of day
hey does that open up fishing
opportunities
as you may know heart runs a photography
studio here now i think he's a puppet
undergoing some changes
i think he might be a peter wants to
create a plaza with all sorts i don't
trust him with a little help from his
longtime friend harriet
consider contributing some belts to the
cause
eventually familiar island visitors like
sahara and kit that's cool set up shop
here
oh permanently
reason cyrus can help customize
ready-made furniture that you can't
customize on your own
[Music]
in addition katrina will reveal your
fortune for that day
fingers crossed it'll be a bustling
plaza filled with all sorts of shops you
call it bustling and then you show them
i teach you something the old man
hairstyles ooh neat
oh not neat
you [ __ ] up you done goofed
[Music]
try out some simple stretches by
participating in group stretching at the
plaza i can't believe this game is real
like when you lay all of this out this
game is absolutely ridiculous
you can participate too
look at everybody's mustache oh my god
his little little
apron underneath his tux
by using either controls or emotions
with a joy-con controller
oh man there are not a lot of games that
oh they actually make you stretch
stretch it out together when you i like
that that's to your island or when
visiting actually do stretches
nintendo's all about that huh
um
i don't like a lot of games that are
like this i do love anything that's like
city builder which is how i played
animal crossings like i designed an
island like it's like level design and i
love that
take the early bird ordinance for
example this will make all island
residents awake and active earlier in
the morning
well just pick these things up that best
suits your island pretty brutal regime i
don't know that we want to force people
to do services anything like that have
been upgraded um more exterior options
are available oh my gosh you can modify
your home's exterior to match your
island's landscape
also storage expansion services just got
bigger
previously home storage held up to 2400
items
with three more expansions it now holds
up to five thousand damn there's so many
items dude
that's more than double the items i
forgot what i was saying oh yeah i i i
i don't often love items like the
available cute video game let's see what
else you can do with your miles but
animal crossing just gets me it's so
comfortable it's coming to diy recipes
yeah i love tons of cute [ __ ] am i
kidding but not like the whole concept
being cute you know ingredients like
good economy
wheat cooking
sugar cane what
potato okay this is actually awesome
carrots and more
why not make a delicious meal from your
bountiful harvest
what do you do with it oh
it's just like yakuza
[Music]
that's tasty
you can make all sorts of dishes to live
oh my god i love it oh i'm gonna put
pizza everywhere i have a pizza oven
outside my house
in in the game
with a pro decorating license lighting
and ceiling decor can be added to each
room dude i'm hyped about cooking that
rules that's that's gonna be neat
all cute accent walls will also be
available to give a single wall a
different pattern
with these more design options will be
at your disposal that's
nice
the maximum number of bridges and
inclines you can place on your island
well that's annoying to 10 each
i really could have used that while i
was designing the island in the first
place including park fencing block
fencing and corrugated iron fencing will
be added letting you diversify your
island even more i will do that
some fencing can be customized too damn
it oh i have so much work to do now
i'm i humor app on your nook phone is
getting updated i so meticulously
designed everything with the eight
restriction that i'm annoyed that
they've added
[Music]
oh my gosh
we hope you can capture more memories
from new perspectives and angles
patterns that were previously used for
customizing items can now be worn
oh that seems really easy
like custom designs that is suspiciously
simple
i feel like this game had a bunch of
objects gameplay garbage even hairstyles
will be added look at them go
including the ones that harriet will
teach you
[Music]
11 new reactions like waving goodbye
this is this is how you wave goodbye
this is how i live goodbye to all my
friends personally i just sort of all
right well as well see ya communicating
even more with these reactions unless i
just mistook that and roasted it for no
reason but that's what it looked like to
me
a new nook phone app island life 101
provides tips on enjoying your island
rest assured newcomers you'll be able to
ease into island living
[Music]
additionally you'll be able to acquire
more furniture by redeeming your nook
miles oh i love the nook miles furniture
because it's so easy to get from the
day's activities
[Music]
this storage shed will come in
handy it connects to your home storage
and can be placed almost anywhere on
your island that's so close to easily
store items or take them out
and when you need some belts from your
account
should also come in
handy you don't have to
go into buildings to get stuff look at
them making the video game look at them
guys
can't believe it the live concert at the
plaza every saturday will release
additional songs keep an ear out for 12
more hits flip him like kk break
and kk polka oh my god
you can even enjoy them from this
gorgeous sounding music box a newly
added furniture item
[Laughter]
looks like something's buried
underground oh
my god
it's
a gyroid why why'd he do what he do in
the ground fragments then plant and
water them they demand money from you're
into a lovely gyroid overnight and then
do they demand that you give them money
what do they do if gyroids have grown on
your island you may find more the day
after it rains
[Music]
gyroids make rather interesting sounds
experiments with different gyroid
combinations i don't use them with music
to bask game is so silly if i were to
explain this to somebody i'd be like
yeah so this dog like sings songs and
everybody sits by the campfire in the
concert and you're like that's in a
video game yeah and i'm hyped about kk
polka types available it's a game of
death decor
it's just ridiculous also get furniture
it's never been seen before
an amazing machine what's amazing about
it there's a new type of tool you can
craft
[Music]
you'll be able to permanently place
ladders on cliffs with a ladder setup
kit
damn
i can ah man i have my work cut out for
me it's feel like it feels like i'm
returning to a job after a holiday i'm
like [ __ ] we got work to do out here
this diy recipe can be purchased from
nooks cranny
narrow spaces in a room
[Music]
news
now you can walk through them like this
cool great way to navigate tight spots
and rooms with lots of furniture on
display these really are upgrades let's
not forget keeping up your relationships
like quality of life upgrades like i'm
i'm impressed i'm this is more than i
expected and i was already
excited they may invite you over to
their home
or make a surprise visit to yours
what do you think great you might
experience this content in various ways
some of them outside of what we've shown
you today
this free update version 2.0 launches
november 5th
i look forward to it
yeah i'll get back to screen streaming
animal processing it'll be the last
major free content i think i only ever
did like a couple of new horizons
[Music]
we hope you'll continue enjoying your
remember
how are you trying to take my money
oh
that went by real fast oh okay there's
another 23 minutes
excuse me
i read that wrong 23 minutes total we've
been recording for 13.
something new is on the horizon
vas
[Music]
our destination is this archipelago made
up of several islands
no i really thought that was it it's
still cool cal is popular among
characters searching for their ideal
vacation homes
pretty
this is animal crossing new horizons
happy home parents paid i see i see i
see
that answered my previous question a
quick reference from tom nook you'll
assist paradise planning a resort
developer in designing vacation homes
i generally do not buy dlc i haven't in
quite some time through your work you'll
be in charge of coordinating dream
lifestyles for characters
maybe i don't know we'll see probably
not though
probably stick to the freak the goal of
paradise planning is to help characters
acquire their dream vacation homes
characters with various dreams come to
visit the office on this island
[Music]
for example meet maple
her dream vacation home is filled with
lots and lots of bears
let's make her dream a reality
first select the island on which the
vacation home will be built
each other has distinctive features
looks like there's tons of them but
they're really small from island to
island
pick the island that best matches the
request then head on over to the
[Music]
site once you arrive on the island take
a tour of the home
place the designated furniture requested
by the client
i don't think i'd find this fun if i'm
being completely honest like i think
it's cool it's a cool edition
[Music]
recommended furniture from paradise
planners will already be available
maybe the way that i approached my
island was like a theme park like i have
all these start designing separate areas
of different sections and maybe
[Music]
that's really specific i don't know
it looks
fantastic while you're at it why not
suggest ideas for the yard
not only can you play sports this is a
tune though when can i get this on
spotify also build fences
plant trees
and create pads
[Music]
the home's location and exterior can be
modified too dude if only that didn't
cost me and with the ability fifty
thousand dollars or whatever [ __ ] time
of day wow
okay so this is bringing a design very
much like a minecraft creative footage
[Music]
it is pretty cool
terrain
as you continue designing vacation homes
you'll acquire various design techniques
[Music]
for example adjusting the size of the
interior by modifying its width or
length more creative design options will
become available
whoa
in addition you can use partition walls
to divide the space
oh it's like the sims basis with two
different heights oh my god it's totally
like the sims
and pillars that support the ceiling
why do we need to worry about the
structural integrity of ceilings now she
can help change how the home is
structured
what the heck lighting can be adjusted
as well to enhance the overall mood
and you can incorporate this is really
cool i still don't know if i'll buy it
the home's atmosphere
but i'm super impressed
can give a finishing touch to the
interior design
polish your furniture with care and some
effects may be added
[Music]
stupid videos give your furniture a new
flourish
after a hard day's work
to the office to get compensated for
your efforts
the shop space within the office sells
rare furniture that may be harvested
oh my god once purchased you can take it
home with you
i mean this is a pretty beefy dlc this
is like a whole separate video game
which is pretty impressive
also i'm sorry if i sound nasally i've
got allergies as you receive more
requests more furniture will become
available
why not visit clients you've helped out
before
it might be good to suggest remodeling
their vacation home with different
furniture
[Music]
hmm
what's up with everybody in that giant
bathroom
we hope they love sharing their new
piece of paradise
[Music]
say
the island on which lottie's paradise
planning office is located has a lot of
vacant buildings
you can help lottie design these as well
to make your island even more robust so
many of these designs are so nice
design one by drawing inspiration from
your own memories or craft the school of
your dreams instead
whoa
other facilities such as a restaurant
can also be developed
dude
i really do want to do this you may be
delighted seeing others using the
facilities you've designed
[Music]
the vacation homes you design are
captured in photos as design samples
then recorded in the paradise planning
portfolio
to view the portfolio use this nook
phone app happy home network
from the app you can visit the homes of
previous clients and see how they're
doing
by connecting online you'll be able to
share your design with people from all
over the world yeah but is it going to
take me like 10 minutes and kick
everybody out of my island or whatever
and view their designs think about it
mark inspiration for your own
[Music]
use the animal crossing series amiibo
figures and amiibo cards to invite
clients of your choosing and discuss
their ideal vacation homes
with amiibo you can design vacation
homes for these busy individuals
[Music]
the vacation homes you design for them
will hopefully make them very happy yeah
give those trash pandas a nice trash
home for that trash personalities
design techniques acquired while working
with a paradise planning team can be
used on your island okay i was really
hoping that i would say that wait wait
that means experiment with partition
walls
you have to buy the dlc to get these
lighting
that means you have to buy the dlc to
learn the techniques oh you couldn't
even get it from a friend your own
furniture to spruce up your home
and by gifting your wrist what are you
doing with that bread and slapping it
about like that
calm down interested in what the
archipelago
they may even ask you to design a
vacation home for them i don't love that
because that means that people who
bought the dlc will have
much cooler islands after you've
designed a certain number of homes you
might even be able to suggest home
remodels to your island residents
[Music]
what do you think
there's a spot open for you to join
their team and start designing oh my god
animal crossing
cousins happy home paradise launches on
november 5th as paid additional content
for animal crossing new horizons
i should have cut this out sorry
everybody pre-orders begin october 29th
on nintendo eshop
you can purchase animal crossing new
horizons happy home paradise on its own
or experience the paid additional
content as part of nintendo switch
online plus expansion pack the new
membership plan for nintendo switch
online
please visit the official website for
more details on nintendo switch online i
feel like i'm gonna do it i feel like
the n64 got me but that being included
in addition the fifth series of the
animal crossing amiibo cards will be
available
48 cards including characters previously
not on amiibo cards as well as new ones
will be released at the same time as the
update that's pretty neat
series 5 of the animal crossing amiibo
cards will be released on november 5th
check your local retailer for details
[Music]
and relish in the new design experience
ridiculous adorable video game
you know what i'm saying
how is this real november 5th and like
enjoyable i don't get it fundamentally i
don't understand
oh wow i thought that was awesome i
i enjoyed it i had a good time i think a
lot of that content looks really great
um those are kind of the updates that i
feel like i was looking for
um
i'm gonna return totally they got me i'm
stoked about it so
yeah it's been a good morning all right
thanks nintendo i appreciate you